joining us on the line is peter schiff
chief economist and global strategist of
euro pacific
capital he's also author of the book the
real crash peter thanks so much for
joining us i really appreciate it
ben thanks for having me on let me say
i've been a fan of your program for
quite some time and it's an honor to
finally be a guest
oh thanks i appreciate it so let's just
jump right in with the the state of the
economy so obviously the stock market is
doing really well there's a lot of
economic optimism gdp growth is going to
be extremely high because we just went
through
the greatest artificial depression in
american history created by
an extraneous shock event and also
governments just shutting down their
economies and now we're
back into a sort of natural growth cycle
that has been dampened it seems a little
bit
at least by the government passing out
stimulus checks to keep people from
re-entering the workforce
but there's some clouds on the horizon
and those clouds seem to be gaining a
lot a lot of force
in the in the form of joe biden's
massive spending packages that he's
trying to push forward now
well first of all there's nothing
natural about this so-called recovery
because we haven't really recovered
the economy is actually sicker now than
it was before
covid and what's really been hurting it
was not the disease
but the government's cure see here's the
problem when
governments around the country ordered
businesses to close and people not to go
to work
everybody stop producing so if you are
helping to produce goods
you're not producing the goods if you're
performing services you stop performing
those services
now if people aren't productive well
they need to reduce their consumption
because you can't consume stuff that's
not produced but the government didn't
want people to stop spending
even though it ordered them to stop
working so what happened was the federal
reserve just printed up all this money
and gave it to businesses uh you know
for the ppp program
gave it to workers and extended
unemployment benefits
sent out all the stimulus money so you
have an economy where we're producing
less
but everybody wants to spend more that's
not economic growth that's massive
inflation and what we're seeing now
is the byproduct of everybody's spending
all this money that we just printed and
that's what's goosing the gdp
but this is not a real economy our trade
deficits are exploding
we've never seen merchandise trade
deficits this high
what we've done is we've substituted
real economic growth
real goods production for money printing
and we're about to pay the price
in terms of an enormous increase in the
cost of goods and services it's going to
be
like the 1970s only a much worse economy
and much higher inflation i've been
saying it's an inflationary depression
not just stagflation so what do you
think the timeline on that looks like
because we're looking at
economic growth at least in gdp numbers
at least through the end of the year you
have all of the
the economic firms like goldman sachs
suggesting up to eight percent gdp
growth
for the year uh we are going to see
people getting back into the workforce i
mean we've seen high ring is up
uh so what do you think the actual
timeline here is because there seems to
be a gamble that's being made by the
biden administration which is they can
raise taxes raise regulations blow out
the spending
do all of this and the economy will
recover to such an extent that it'll
sort of carry past
all of those obstacles for the next
couple of years and then if a crash
comes it'll only happen three four years
from now
well actually all this government
spending is inhibiting
an actual recovery from taking place
because whenever the government spends
money
it has to deprive the free market of
those resources right
it's not the taxation that's the problem
it is the spending
government spending is effectively
taxation so once the government decides
to spend money
the question is how do we pay for it now
the most obvious way
is you know we send the government our
money through an income tax or sales tax
whatever it is
but if they don't have the political
guts to ask the americans to pay
for all the spending that they're
delivering then they ask the federal
reserve to print money
but that doesn't mean we get the
government for free it just means the
government is robbing us
of the purchasing power of our money and
that's what's happening the government
is creating money
putting it into the economy giving it to
people to spend these people are bidding
up prices
and that's what's driving the gdp it's
higher prices
and more spending as we are producing
less right that's why you see
this enormous trade deficits but i get
all
this all these stories from people that
email me and i experience it myself
there is a widespread shortage of stuff
stuff you know you have to order
things it takes months and months to get
them there's a huge backlog
and prices are really going up now the
federal reserve is
asking us to believe that what we're
seeing is just
transitory that it's gonna it's gonna
blow over
and it's it's nothing that should
concern us but this is exactly what the
federal reserve said
in 2005 2006 about subprime
they told us ignore what's happening in
the subprime mortgage market
it's contained it's not going to be a
problem for the mortgage market
it's not a problem for housing it's not
a problem for the economy
just ignore it it's no big deal well the
federal reserve was completely wrong
about the subprime market being
contained they're now
just as wrong if not more so more so
about inflation being transitory
are at the beginning of a huge
escalation
in the cost of living and they are
throwing gasoline on the fire right now
uh by continuing to spend more money
paid for by the printing press
even though they're talking about
raising taxes on the rich the amount of
revenue that those higher taxes are
actually going to raise
is going to compel in comparison to the
money that they want to spend
and that particular type of taxation
that's targeted
at the rich what ends up happening is
the rich don't spend less
they invest less and investing is what
drives economic growth because
investments is what creates you know
productivity
businesses jobs that doesn't come from
what rich people spend
it comes from what rich people don't
spend but if the government takes that
money
instead it depresses the economy so
we're going to depress the economy at
the same time we're printing up a bunch
of money
and the government has created such a
perverse incentive
you have so many americans that have
left the workforce
they have no desire to return to their
jobs because the government has given
them a better deal
it is more lucrative not to work than to
go and get a job
and of course it's far more enjoyable to
have a vacation
and get paid more than you would get if
you return to work
so the government is paying people not
to produce and then giving them money to
buy the stuff that they didn't produce
this is going to be an inflationary
apocalypse so peter one of the things
that is so amazing about all this is as
you say
uh if it requires you know rich people
putting their money in the stock market
or rich people starting companies
to actually you know raise the
production to to meet
pricing is what you're talking about
here and and then you have
on the other end the biden
administration saying they're gonna tax
capital gains
at exorbitant rates i mean it's
basically saying to to the rich
you have no place to put your money like
there's there's no place to put your
money you can't put your money in real
estate because it's a bubble you can't
put your money
in the stock market because you're gonna
get taxed on capital gains at some
crazy rate and so rich people are going
to i mean people wonder where bitcoin is
coming from people are literally just
looking for a place to put their money
where it's not going to be removed from
them
and that may be bubble or it may not be
a bubble given what the governments are
doing right now i know you're not a huge
bitcoin fan
and you have to realize that when the
government is taxing corporations
they're not really taxing corporations
they're taxing the shareholders
of those corporations so it's the people
that own the corporations
that pay that tax then they pay a tax
again
when they collect a dividend or they get
a capital gain
so if we are going to raise both the
corporate tax
and the tax on dividends and capital
gains
that people receive after they've
already paid
the corporate tax the percentage of
total
income that is being confiscated by the
u.s government
will be well in excess of 50 percent i
mean you're talking about levels
that are confiscatory i mean if you go
back to the days of feudalism
when you had lords and you had serfs
what made you a surf was that you only
got to keep 75
of what you produced the lord took 25
and we called that feudalism surfed them
it was very oppressive
well compare that to what we have now i
mean most american businessmen
entrepreneurs
would love to be able to keep 75 of what
they earn because very few people do
and now the government wants to take
even more people are going to spend more
time
avoiding income than generating income
and it's the activity
to generate income that drives the
economic cra
train that's the goose that lays the
golden eggs because if
i want to produce income i have to
provide consumers
with goods and services that improve
their lives and i have to employ other
people
to help me do that so the minute the
government you know
stamps out the desire to make more money
because the government is taking
so much of what's being produced all
that economic activity goes away
and even though they keep saying hey
these these
tax increases are targeted at the rich
so if you make less than 400 000
you don't have to worry about it well
maybe you end up losing your job
because the person who is going to
employ you no longer has the desire or
the capital
to provide you with a job so peter i
asked you before but
i want to re-up how fast does this
manifest we're already starting to see
price inflation in a wide variety of
areas in american life but when does
this actually turn into
the sort of stagflation that we saw in
the 70s or even something
worse than that when do americans start
to feel this so severely that it becomes
a political issue for the people in
power
well i think that trigger is going to be
the exchange value of the us dollar
see what's happening now and our get out
of jail free card
is that even though you have a lot of
americans who aren't working
you have a lot of people in other
countries who are working let's say
china
you have all these people who are going
to work they're in factories they're
producing all this stuff
and then they load it up on container
ships and they send it to america
so even though americans aren't
producing we still get to consume
because we live off the fruits
of the labor of people in china and
other parts of the world now the reason
that chinese are willing
to give us their products that you know
they actually had to use real resources
to create
they needed capital they needed labor
the reason they're willing to give us
this
is because we're giving them dollars but
all the dollar is is a piece of paper
doesn't have any actual real value like
all the consumer goods that we're
getting from china
they're just getting ious now when the
chinese and the rest of the world
lose confidence in the future purchasing
power of those
ious they're not going to want to accept
them anymore in exchange for their stuff
and then what's going to happen is
you're going to see the dollar really
start to fall
on foreign exchange markets and that's
when the inflation
chickens are really going to come home
to roost in a way that it's impossible
for the government
to ignore the reality or just point to a
doctored cpi
and try to say oh prices aren't going up
uh
and then this is going to become a real
problem because i think the next
real recession is going to be triggered
by inflation
as the costs go up so much businesses
start
firing people because they need to stay
in you know stay in business
and consumers even though they're
spending a lot of money they're spending
it on food
they're spending it on energy so they
don't have money left over
to buy other stuff and so they have to
stop buying other stuff
and now all the people who earn their
living selling that other stuff
will they lose their jobs and now we're
in a recession
that is caused by inflation and now what
does the federal reserve do because
their normal prescription
for a recession is to create more
inflation print more money
but if you have an inflation problem how
do you pour
gasoline on that problem by creating
even more inflation you can't
so the fed is in a box that they can't
get out of so peter
um when when it comes to you know
inflation there are a lot of concerns
among conservatives particularly that in
2009 uh the barack obama stimulus
packages the raising of the spending
rates from three trillion dollars by the
federal government to four trillion
dollars a year
that that was going to lead to some sort
of runaway inflation it didn't really
materialize
what is the difference this time as
opposed to what happened during the last
recession
well first of all again we got to
remember that inflation
by definition is the expansion of the
money supply right that is literally
what is being inflated
uh because prices don't expand prices go
up prices go down
it's money supply that can expand and
contract and
if you go back and get an old webster's
dictionary even from the 1970s
and you look up inflation it will define
it as an expansion of the money supply
now at some point they added to the
definition an expansion of the money
supply
that results in a rise in prices but the
rise in prices
was a result of inflation it wasn't the
inflation itself
so we had a lot of inflation uh
following the 2008 financial crisis and
i think
the initial effect of that inflation was
that it prevented
prices from going down prices were set
to fall
which would have been a relief to the
economy so that during tough times
the cost of living could have gone down
but the inflation that was created
prevented those prices from falling and
so you just don't notice it
uh in that respect but it was still
there but also what happened was the
dollar
in 2008 when we had the financial crisis
the dollar was at an all-time record low
and if you remember where commodity
prices were
oil prices had just moved up to 140 a
barrel
uh all commodities were going way up and
when the financial crisis
actually happened commodity prices
collapsed
and the dollar rose and so that was like
a buffer
and that helped spare us uh from a more
protracted increase in consumer prices
and we were able to rely more heavily
on foreign imports during that period
where the dollar was strengthening
but fast forward to where we are today
commodities are just starting a new bull
market
the dollar is starting a new bear market
and the size of today's deficits dwarf
i mean we were running at most a
trillion dollar deficit
uh at the peak maybe 1.1 1.2
uh when bush left office and obama came
in we're now at like 4 trillion
the government is is printing almost 70
percent of the money it spends i mean
it's
the government is spending uh what eight
trillion dollars almost and
not even collecting three and a half
trillion in taxes this is
unprecedented when we started the
inflation in 2008 the fed's balance
sheet
was maybe seven eight hundred billion
it's now almost eight
trillion uh so we're at a much bigger
point
and if you go back to 2008 2009
the fact that we were borrowing a lot of
money but the chinese were lending us
the money
the japanese were lending us the money
the saudis the russians
the whole world was lending the us
government money they're not doing that
anymore
we have to do it all by ourselves the
fed is not the buyer of last resort
it's the buyer of only resort so we
can't rely
on other countries to loan us the money
the fed has to print the money
plus you go back to 2008 social security
was still a net um lender to the u.s
government because the social security
system was collecting more in payroll
taxes
than it was paying out in benefits
that's the opposite today
today social security is not collecting
enough taxes
to cover the benefits it's paying so it
is also now selling us
treasuries whereas in 2008 it was buying
us treasuries
so i think it's night and day where we
are right now and i think the fed
it's a false sense of complacency to
think that oh we dodged the bullet last
time
so we're going to dodge it again this
isn't a bullet this time this is a hand
grenade and we're stepping right on it
that's peter schiff chief economist
global strategist of euro pacific
capital peter thanks so much for your
time great to talk to you
thanks a lot ben for having me on i hope
you enjoyed that clip from the ben
shapiro show if you did go ahead and hit
that subscribe button so you stay up to
date with all our future content